a very consistent player Milan luch back with
Boston the team he began his NHL career with
Lich won a cup with the Bruins back in 2011
we're underway and in quickly the Bruins a
shot by makavo is turned aside by talit and
everyone interchanges positions he makes the
move let's put ahead watch he's going to keep
going keep going pass up but back and all of a
sudden two-on one the Boston Bruins you talk about
kempe dropping for fiala and ahead to Kopitar back
in front Kee chance save rebound dub stopped by
San pass coming up right there all the way one
touch and then that speed through the middle
of Kee normally Kee is the puck carrier right
this time he becomes the receiver he tries to go
tweeners swayman just gets the p in the middle DY
for Kee right dot across the fiia shot pass gone
save is made loose Puck ruins away with it what
we haven't talked about is kopitar's durability
in his career Kee up high a shot save rebound
a scramble Roy a chance I think it hit a body in
front Defan for the Kings has been Matt Roy Kings
WI a face off bodies in front look at Matt on the
left left side of the screen he he he had did not
hesitate at all all the way to the net now look
at swayan in behind all of that San po the rookie
Center in the left wing Corner feeds it out to
the blue line lindol to Patra feeds the middle
of shot sa rebound shot wide by Carlo the first
opportunity van Reams Dy Bruins buzzing van rsd's
pass hit the side of the net now Carlo a drive
blocker save penalty coming up on the play you
can almost sense that coming poock and Van rdik
are both out and off the draw van rdik three
goals early on poster knock with four marshan
is out there feeds it left Circle shot and they
score David poster knock now with goals in four
straight games to start the season one nothing
Bruins you see him worked out to win the face
off so he does some dirty work before the puck
ends up back to him watch his reaction after he
scores here I don't think he even knew it went
in originally and then he's kind of he's the last
guy on the ice to react to the situation one stick
handle one look maybe a contact off the stick now
the penalty Killers who have been very strong so
far at the beginning of this season they have to
come up with a big kill here to start the second
keep the deficit at one so no icing more with
it more plays it ahead here's a breakaway Den
in hit the post Philip Doo with a short-handed bid
but he rang it off that right post do know again
after the Bruins clear do know curl and Dre can he
move in no more denied a chance block attempt kept
alive and the Bruins have a one- nothing lead
Bruins playing their fourth game have scored
10 goals and ostock with his goal tonight has
half of them he's got five lead pass onside
lafier shoots scars there is his first NH a goal
Alex lafier and the game is tied at one and then
what pressure comes again right himself for
the shot fiala starts it down oh wow nice
passing look at this Puck protection now he
gets his head up then he gets some Leverage
he has to go down to his knees to do so but
that shows control strength and accuracy but
what a passing play fiala long pass to DUIs so
far tonight we're tied at one Moore gains the
line nice move at the base of the right Circle
threw it in front tipped on a one-onone one on
two one on Three at times protects one time
protects the second time and then finally
makes a chance out of it brings it out on the
right Wing side wrist it down low for geeky
a rangy right shot is geeki feeds the Blue Line
shot forbert off the post the X King rattles it
off iron forbert again a shot save rebound score
geeky and the Bruins regain the lead at two to
one a shift the Bruins control basically all
shift long recognizes the fact that his team
was not getting the Puck to the net so he got
to the net once and then the second time right
there he gets to the net no better example right
there gaboff and Dy all used to eating up big
ice corbert off the draw hands it off now Maran
to bid and they score might have been tipped or
maybe off a king between the pads marshand may
get credit for it now it's 3-1 Boston Kopitar
little tap on the pads for CT get that face
off earlier when it cleanly and then just a
couple of timing plays it's a set play you
see how right there it goes off of Kopitar
he's the last guy to hit it for the Kings he
tried to squeeze his legs together again the
set play for that with the Boston Bruins
is that marshan ends up backing off right
skate of anj and look at that game of inches
but you win a face off you go to a certain
spot so he's averaging over three shots on goal
through his first five NHL games talot and Swan
the match up in goal here tonight Kopitar on a
loose Puck to the right Circle a shot attempt is
blocked Kings have the Deno line out now Puck
out to the Blue Line grizzli the shot hit the
post maoy on it right Circle feeds the middle
coil missed the net from 15 ft they would play
each other early in the playoffs and the Bruins
with both Series wins Kee stop rebound by field
stop he created a leg race right there but key
gets in there gets inside position Swan holds
his ground and Byfield so tbut back in for the
time being as poster knock sends it across to
marshand marshand shot from the board it's gloved
by tell but he keeps it alive but marshand up with
it threw it behind behind the net zaka for poster
knock and in front all alone marshan scores the
three forwards for Boston team up third Point
second goal of the game for marshand 4-1 Boston
talit kept alive I don't blame C for doing this
he knows the situation he wants to keep it alive
but with the brunes they're jumping on pucks and
right here coverage just breaks down because the
Kings get caught everyone watching and for some
to be that wide open the control first the spin
poso had a whole bunch of time now then rode
up for that reason I believe they brought it
back so going to make the assumption that is the
adjustment that the officials made sixth power
play for the Kings Tonight the Bruins penalty
killing still perfect on the young season shot Roy
scores might have been chipped in front cruising
in front was Carl brunstrom Miner penalty is now a
factor yep I think the last guy is 91 like I
think you're exactly right there's the good
thing here for the Kings is there's more than
one and it may have hit lazat first and then
grundstrom one two going one side threw
it around the wall Kee for dubis look to
Center the pass is blocked a board battle Deno
fala Dy shoots blocked ruins away with it lob
it down the ice knocked out the air by fala at
the Kings line now an EMP net shot by Patrick
Brown is blocked by den and that'll do it here
tonight at crypto.com Arena 4-2 the final Boston